اشتبكت شرطه مكافحه الشغب الفرنسيه مع
متظاهرين في باريس حيث خرجت مظاهره جديده
ضد قرار الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد في البلاد
وقد استخدمت الشرطه الغاز المسيل للدموع
للتعامل مع اضطرابات اضطراب الحشود بينما
تجمع المتظاهرون في ساحه الكونكورد بباريس
بالقرب مبنى البرلمان اجواء تراقب وحذر
تعيشها العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس دعوات
عشوائيه للتظاهر يستجيب لها الطلاب وتحشد
لها الشرطه قواتها امام مقر البرلمان
مستفيدين من ورشات صيانه في ساحه
الكونكورد امام البرلمان صنع المتظاهرون
حواجزهم ووضعوها امام الشرطه
هدفوا لاسقاط الرئيس وغنوا باجواء
احتفاليه اشعل النيران وغذو لهيبها ثم
القوا ماكرون مجسم بداخلها
دقائق قليله وتبدا المعركه ازدياد اعداد
المتظاهرين وبلوغها اربعه الاف شخص دفع
الشرطه لفض التظاهر بالقوه رشقات حجاره
ومقذوفات من المتظاهرين الذين احتلوا
الساحه لخمس ساعات ردت عليها الشرطه
بالقنابل المسيله للدموع حتى تمكنت من
عزلهم وتقسيمهم الى مجموعات
ومحاصره كل واحده على حده فاجبرتهم على
المغادره عنوه وكذلك فعلت مع وسائل
الاعلام التي رافقتها عناصر الشرطه للتاكد
من مغادرتها استعاده الشرطه سيطرتها على
الوضع في الميدان مثلا انتصارا صغيرا
لمعركه انتهت اليوم في الشارع وستبدا
الاسبوع المقبل في البرلمان مع اعلان حزب
التجمع الوطني من اقصى اليمين بزعامه
مارلوبين طرح اول مذكره حجب للثقه عن
الحكومه لقد قمنا بطرح مذكره حجب الثقه عن
الحكومه
ايضا سنقوم بالتصويت على اي مذكره حجبي
ثقه اخرى تطرح من اجل اسقاط الحكومه مذكره
اقصى اليمين لم تكن الوحيده اذ اعلنت كتله
النواب المستقلين طرح مذكره من جهتها
ستصوت عليها قوى اليسار الخمس في البرلمان
مجتمعه
سيكون من المفيد لدينا نصوت على مذكره حجب
الثقه لاسقاط قانون رفع سن التقاعد غير
العادل وغير المفيد ذلك سيكون من اجل حفظ
الديمقراطي البرلمانيه والاجتماعيه
والى ان يجتمع البرلمان مجددا يوم الاثنين
المقبل للتصويت على مذكرتي حجب الثقه
ستخيم على شوارع العاصمه مشاهد انتشار
قوات الامن خوفا من امتداد رقعه الحريق
الذي اشعله الرئيس الى كل المدن الفرنسيه
على ما تقول المعارضه
فدهوك العربيه باريس